[Musique]
un trésor où ça rend dans l'histoire
dans une période bien particulière allez
viens à ça
bonjour Marina
alors mon trésor aujourd'hui c'est ça
c'est la statue donc c'est une
représentation de Shiva et représente
dans la religion hindoue la fertilité
là et avant de repartir dans d'autres
pays donc pour remercier votre patron
aux autres médecins ici en remerciement
OK et yaourt
donc il laisse là par respect
alors que c'est les histoires cette
maison là alors ici dit il était une
ancienne écurie qui probablement été à
la famille de kervigen donc il a été
construit depuis les années 1826 donc
après ensuite il a été une rhumerie et
après mon cousin a racheté ici il y a 25
ans de ça et après donc lui-même lui a
réaménage le lieu et quand il a voulu
planter un pied de bois il y a plein de
sa pioche et il a dit non on en a à
faire les pas normal donc du coup il y
avait un deux fois deux fois et après il
lui a découvert ça les pavés on lave là
que vive voix c'est lui-même la
découverte ça donc les d'origine depuis
les années 1826
mais quand mon cousin invite à moi ici
on m'avait 20 ans à peu près au moment
d'un repas de famille marathon vraiment
amoureuse du lieu il
face à un truc et que ça et en fait
comme un fil au lycée hôtelier donc
juste après mes études j'avais pour
projet en fait de faire les chambres
d'hôtes donc là le lieu s'y prête donc
depuis un an et demi il fait ça
en tout cas bravo c'est un super projet
merci et Nana question même bien pose
quel endroit pour faire le plus qu'on
lit ici ah ben ce qui est la cuisine
parce que dans la cuisine il fait les
plats créoles que les clients ils
découvrent que peut être chaud de voir
quoi il peut être pas admise et tout il
y en a quoi donc toutes les frais les
faits maison et les clients aiment ça et
puis il dit il rendra la cuisine fait un
coup il mange à soi donc du coup bah
voilà c'est mon endroit si vous trouvez
pas moi ici c'est dans la cuisine
s'il te plaît
et ben voilà notre émission l'affini
pouzaudi avec la case madame rattan
avait un magnifique trésor la divinité
indienne et un gars histoire c'est la
casse mais n'est pas fini moi ça a
continué la réunion je vous fais
découvrir
[Musique]
mon moment ça mon soleil